now it's it's incredible how a tiny
little thing in terms of rephrasing the
question makes things a lot simpler so
for instance this looks difficult some
of you have got it and it does fall out
very simply if you know what you're
doing but others you look at this is not
how can I possibly integrate this before
we use the trig identity right but it's
like what what kind of what do you even
do with that right on some of you guys
have more partial fractions maybe but
that doesn't tend to be very useful
thing how do you break it down well let
me rewrite what we're trying to prove
I'll just change it in a teeny little
way and then you told me if you can see
it
now what difference does this make and
the answer is well not a whole lot all
I've done is move this guy over here but
it helps you to remember that you
actually know exactly what I am minus 1
is because you know what I n is right no
this is so they show up therefore you
should know what this is ok it looks
like it turns out to be something simple
so let's give it a go
okay if I say I am minus 1 okay where is
the amphibian it's just in his power
isn't it ok so I've got the integral X
to the n minus 4 honey on X plus 1
problems that's ok
now if I add this to my original
integral this Plus this this plus X
watch ok I am plus I am minus 1 well
they've defined I am for us there it is
we've just determined what the next or
the previous one actually is next to the
N minus 1 the great thing this is you're
integrating with respect to the same
variable you've even got the same
denominator right so therefore you can
take these two integrals and make one
out of them this should be X to the N
plus X to the n minus 1 on the numerator
right all over X plus 1 now look you
know where you're headed right from the
beginning you know the end so therefore
you want to be able to expect what you
can do with this thing look can I not
take out a factor what would be a good
choice a factor
if I take out X to the N minus one okay
X to the N minus one let's take it out
the front how many X's am I left with
you what X how many things are left with
here just one okay cancel cancel what's
the integral of xn minus 1
I'm pretty sure is to be in one is
really is that all we had to do well
almost
I suppose I should tidy up I want this
over here I don't need to put the
constant because I still have integrals
play around oh no okay
so yeah take that - snap and there's
your recurrence relation right no
integration by parts no trig identities
no nothing you just rearrange things a
little bit okay
but because if it's 1 in the recurrence
relation is let's figure